i want to jump to this uh story here
this is breaking news cnn recently
announced they're not going to be saying
breaking news but this one is from cnn
business the washington post suspends
reporter david weigle over a sexist
retweet
okay now before we get into this i would
like to shout out senator ben sasse who
said that weirdos are running the
political space it's an algorithm driven
by rage and he's he's half right
but he's not completely right there are
weirdos running things but it's not the
french this is becoming mainstream
politics don't believe me
dave weigel
retweeted a joke on twitter probably
he's probably sitting on the toilet he's
probably like look at his phone he's
like it's a joke oh what's that that's
funny retweet anyway what was i doing
and then all of a sudden a bunch of
women at the company starts freaking out
saying he's sexist
and now he's suspended from his job this
is a guy who's reported on on seth rich
he's report i mean this is this is a
high-profile political reporter with 600
000 followers who's been suspended for
retweeting a joke on twitter he didn't
say anything to us to his co-workers
just retweeting it this is twitter being
the real world
i can't imagine what it's like to work
at the washington post oh and also don't
forget we got the story about taylor
lorenz lying about these youtubers so
here's the sh do they i wonder if they
have the joke on uh
you look that up but this is my first
response to this from all the treachery
from all the horrible things that the
corporate mainstream media has done wmds
banker bailouts lying through their
teeth
putting innocent people at the fray
because they they smirked
lying libeling destroying people's
livelihoods going to grandma's homes
because they opened up a facebook page
doxxing individuals this is what you
punish them for
a retweet of a joke are you kidding me
this shows you the fake
nonsense bull crap that is really
happening behind the corporate media i
mean you worked you worked in the
corporate media you probably know pr and
hr and all this other stuff that happens
behind the scenes but why do you think
this happened why would they why would
they punish him yeah was it really the
outcry or is it them just trying to out
woke that well yes you know to me and do
you want to read the joke well i want to
have it no we cannot read this on air
it's [ __ ] it actually it actually
says watching oh i was like you can't it
actually says why they did it
so the joke was quote every girl is bi
you just have to figure out if it's
polar or sexual
he retweeted that
felicia sanmez had recently had a
discrimination lawsuit against the paper
dismissed a decision her attorney has
said she plans to appeal
there it is so they're trying to protect
their their bottom dollar i mean that's
what it comes down to but to me what
felicia did fully in her name of course
has to be felicia what felicia did after
this
is worse and when you're talking about
the actual culture of a newsroom and
having worked in mainstream media
newsrooms can be very
challenging places to work but i and
i've worked in really toxic ones but if
i had an issue with something that a
co-worker tweeted and i'd had co-workers
who had issues with something i tweeted
they walked across the room and they
told me about it or they picked up the
phone or they sent a text so felicia
gets on there and shames publicly
her co-worker for retweeting this and
then i don't know if you guys saw this
jose del rio he also works for the
washington post he called her out on it
on twitter and he's basically like hey
you know said essentially what i said is
if you have a problem like go talk to
him but this is toxic to be calling him
out on twitter so he's since deleted all
that and i feel so bad for this guy he
he put out a tweet saying last night i
came under an unrelenting series of
attacks intended to tarnish my
professional and personal reputation the
cause some tweets i sent calling for
compassion within our workplace and so
he talked about all the attacks and he
briefly deleted his twitter account took
it down over it yeah and he works at the
podcast so you made a very good point
about the fact that if you were working
at a news outlet what you would do is
speak to someone who said something
offensive to you unfortunately i and you
know this is just my own perspective
they haven't said this but i would
venture to guess that their goal was not
to have any kind of problem solved it
was just to grandstand and from the
public and virtue signal and show
everybody how put upon they are having
to work for this news network how
difficult their life is the question is
would you rather have a co-worker who
retweets offensive things in their off
time or a co-worker who will smear you
in front of the public without ever
having a conversation with you about it
prior that's my way
i got a better one for you or would you
rather have a co-worker who fabricates
the news ladies and gentlemen i would
like to pull up this story from
newsdiffs.org
our good friend dave weigel deserves to
have been fired five years ago not
suspended over a sexist retweet why
because dave weigel effectively
fabricated a story about seth rich
essentially accusing kim.com of trying
to hack gmail to plant false evidence
news diffs shows that the original
article on may 24th 2017 was edited
november 18th 2017 and completely
changed i'll give you the simple version
first the image i'm showing the green is
the latest the red is what removed
what weigel was trying to insinuate was
that because seth rich's gmail account
received an alert from mega.com
that means in all likelihood kim.com was
trying to hack the email to plant fake
evidence in reality people on 4chan had
posted that they signed up they put
sethurdge's gmail into mega to see if
they would get a ping back for an
existing account this triggered a
welcome email to go to the email account
and then the washington post fabricated
a story i reached out to dave weigle for
comment he didn't correct it until
several months later without notice and
without an editor's note or a correction
the story just changes completely see
they don't fire people for things like
this now what's fascinating about this
is think about how this impacts things
like wikipedia this story will be used
as a as a factual reference to kim.com
hacking gmail or trying to and they'll
cite the washington post who six months
later will change the story but
wikipedia won't change
these people
are
what's the what's the right word you
know i feel like
evil
is is going easy on them den of scum
lords yeah so you know what dave dave
you should have been fired for this
your your institution is garbage taylor
lorenz deserves to work for the new for
the washington post and everything
coming their way it's exactly what you
deserve jeff bezos is a scumbag he
bought it congratulations on your trash
investment yeah i would argue one of the
signs and one of the most obvious
straightforward signs of a failing
system or society is that the mainstream
institutions are no longer operating in
accordance with their purpose so the
dominant media culture in this country
has been pretty dishonest for a very
long time this is not a recent
development but the fact that somebody
who works for the media which is
purportedly there to expose us to
important truths would not get in
trouble for publishing a story which had
fabricated information in it or tried to
insinuate things were some other way
than they were in reality
the fact that that's acceptable he
doesn't get in trouble for that but he
does get in trouble for this retweet
shows not simply that it's the case that
this institution is no longer operating
in accordance with what its purpose
should be but also we can detect what
its new purpose is or what they are
attempting to go for which is to promote
a woke left-wing narrative and because
he fell to do that he was fired well
it's all fruit from the same poisonous
tree i mean it all has to do with that
obsession with virtue signaling i mean
that's why their reporting is so bad
that's in part that's why they're
reporting it so bad and that's why they
would fire him over something like this
i got i got to read you some of this
article you guys are gonna are gonna
laugh all right so here's what happens
mega dot co dot nz that's kim.com's
website you may know kim.com from mega
upload way back in the day
so this is mega.cod.nz it's a news it's
a new zealand top level domain the dot
co dot nz right
that so so here's what he writes
the latest is the original article the
latest revelation that a hacker from new
zealand may have been trying as recently
as this week to hack into rich's email
offered fresh evidence the conspiracy
theory is false dot com it seemed may
have been willing to create a fake
archive of emails from rich to prove his
role in the dnc leak
he changed to say
someone may have been trying to hack
into rich's email offered fresh evidence
the conspiracy theory is false the
family worried that com or someone eager
to prove him right may have been willing
to create a fake archive of emails from
rich or crack a password to see whether
rich had passed on documents with a mega
account
just because the email came from.nz does
not mean a hacker from new zealand but
instead of issuing a correction an
apology and retracting the article they
stealth edit it six months later they
say nothing now if you go back to the
article it's all cleaned up these people
are scumbags well that's like that elon
musk article that which is like it was
new york times right where it talked
about tried to somehow tie him to like
the racist
uh history of of south africa and it was
really odd i mean they totally went
through and scrubbed it and rewrote it
so it was softer because the way they
had written that article initially about
elon musk made it seem like he was his
family and he was like racist and all
this stuff and then they rewrote it in a
way that distanced him from uh from
south africa and from apartheid yeah and
this is the crazy thing these are the
authoritative sources these are the
sources that that big tech social media
runs in their algorithm youtube twitter
facebook they promote these accounts
these individuals these lying scumbags
and and they get
no accountability no transparency and
this is the only time that they get
punished for for retweeting a joke it
it's a joke in itself and it's sick and
it's a sad joke no corrections on this
article i have it right here here's the
actual argument that stands now it says
may 24th 2017 but as i showed news diffs
which i believe is defunct show that it
was edited in november of that year
here's the best part a couple other
mainstream reporters retweeted the story
as fact they retweeted the story right
kim.com did do this and when i reached
out to them they said they effectively
told me to screw off one guy
he i think he worked for buzzfeed a year
later said i must have missed this sorry
i'll take the tweet down that's what
they do a year later they they publish
conspiracies lies and fake news and then
no one fact checks them here's the best
part
newsguard we use newsguard on all of our
sources right yeah we like news guard
but here's the funny thing if the new
york times says it's true newsguard just
assumes it is and then if you get
evidence proving new york times wrong
they'll say you lied because these
people are all in one big
circle
of jerks where they give each other
awards for fake stories like russiagate
and then never investigate and never
give the awards back they do a lot more
sicker stuff behind the scenes but
that's another story family-friendly
show i'm not going to go there i knew
some journalists a lot of them are just
drug addicts
pill poppers
manic depressants and just absolutely
insane people that will do anything for
a buck essentially the corporate media
is pr for the establishment this is the
perfect representation of it uh this
little drama thing shows you the perfect
representation of our current media
state that is filled with absolute
nonsense um and that and that's what it
is and i think these stories need to be
proliferated i think we need to talk
about stealth editing i think we need to
continue to remind people that hey when
you're watching the news you're watching
an agenda you're watching something that
rich people only want you to understand
and know just think about what is okay
at these newsrooms a stupid joke is a
suspension-worthy event publishing fake
news don't worry about it we'll sweep
under the ruining a child's life just
because you're smirked intentionally
suppressing the episode story exactly
right you know
having having victims come forward in
the 90s to you say hey there's this
powerful man with an island doing
unspeakable things to me and all these
thousands of children and just looking
the other way and not reporting on it
absolutely disgusting behavior writing
the story
making the story editing the videos and
then
not publishing it when you have
according to cbs news according to the
project veritas people like bill clinton
that you got him when it comes to this
bigger
story surrounding a mr epstein again
lots of bombshell stuff that that could
help humanity but the reason we can't
have nice things is because of the
corporate media yeah that's my
perspective yeah well i i want to make a
point here there's this old idea or this
line from solzhenitskin you know the the
line between good and evil runs across
every man's heart one thing i would like
to impart to anyone in the mainstream
media if they happen to be listening or
would take any of what we're saying
seriously is that if you want to talk
about combating misinformation right
well the war between misinformation and
truth also runs across everyone's heart
everyone's capable of lying for their
agenda everyone ideally should want to
tell the truth for their agenda
unfortunately it's not the case if you
are so concerned about misinformation
and disinformation spreading
and you think that there is just a flood
of unfounded conspiracy theories and
people don't trust the mainstream media
like they shouldn't so the traditional
gatekeepers are gone maybe don't stealth
edit articles that were promoting
misinformation as if you were telling
the truth the entire time if you are
concerned about the fact that public
trust in the media has eroded you need
to look in the mirror and figure out
ways to improve it's not our fault it's
not as if the media was doing a great
job and then people started making a
living in in making a career out of
working in alternative media you guys
dropped the ball now people are looking
to other sources and you're jealous of
the other sources and you're hating them
instead of trying to figure out what
you're doing wrong one thing i want to
say about jeff bezos i'm gonna make a
prediction i think he's gonna say
something about all this
i think he's gonna i think he's gonna
say something negative about his own
paper about this he's been a little he's
been kind of
coming i mean he said the things about
the white house about inflation elon
musk comment was pretty interesting yeah
he's been he's been saying more things
um that surprised me on twitter
than he has in a long time and so i'm
gonna make a bet that i think he's gonna
say something negative about his own
paper about all this i hope he does
we should he's probably gonna be
partying taking steroids and just
hanging out and not giving not caring
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you